joining us now from pittsburgh to
discuss more is dr amish adalga a senior
scholar at johns hopkins center for
health
security at the bloomberg school of
public health
good morning to you so 10 months now
after the
coronavirus was declared a pandemic we
have two authorized vaccines
you were just vaccinated a day ago first
off how you feeling
and give us a sense of where we are
i'm feeling fine i actually have no
symptoms i've checked in on the cdc app
to report my symptoms and i've had no no
symptoms and it's been about 24 hours
since my first dose so everything is
looking good
you know i think we're in a remarkable
place we've got this great news with
this
with two vaccines that have now reached
emergency use authorization
but i'm on my way to the hospital right
after this interview and i know there's
going to be a lot of covet patients
there
and there's really no end in sight and
we're in this place where the
virus has accelerated its transmission
people's pandemic fatigue is at an
all-time high
and we worry about hospital capacity on
a day-to-day basis and wonder how we're
going to get through christmas
without having to change standards of
care if that pace of cases doesn't slow
we'll talk about holidays here in a
second doctor but first of all here
uh hhs said on this week that the plan
was to give every american a chance
to get vaccinated by june that's just a
little over six months away now is that
realistic
i i do think it's realistic everything
would have to go perfectly but it's in
the realm of possibility we'll
we will likely have two vaccines that
are will be online
and people will be able to get one or
the other depending upon where they live
and we're moving through the different
phases of priority groups it's going to
be harder when we're going into the
community dwelling individuals that are
at high risk and the
average risk people because we have to
make sure that we can actually get this
vaccine into the arms of americans and
we have to make sure that americans want
to take this vaccine
so this is going to be something that's
going to be really challenging
probably one of the biggest public
health efforts if not the biggest public
health effort that we've ever done
but it's the only way that we're going
to put an end to this pandemic doctor as
you know
polling shows that some people are still
really reluctant to get this vaccine
how do public health officials bridge
that gap
we have to be proactive we have to
really model the behavior by ourselves
getting vaccinated
and talking about it and talking about
what side effects we have if any
we also have to be really transparent
about the data the clinical trials
what we know what we don't know we if
there are side effects that occur like
those allergic reactions that happened
in alaska and the united kingdom
we have to talk about those and put that
information out there and we have to set
the tone we can't be responding to
anti-vaccine conspiracy theories
we can't be responding to arbitrary
assertions we really have to show
the value of vaccines and how
life-saving they are and what a triumph
this was for science
aaa estimates that some 84 million
people hit the roads for this holiday
that's about 30 percent less than normal
still a lot of people i know you have
problems with that
what worries you most what worries me
most is when people think that they're
in a situation where the virus isn't
there
and they let their guard down we saw
that at thanksgiving we see that with
private gatherings all the time when
people around their friends and family
they don't social distance they think
that they're not going to be exposed to
the virus and that's where we're seeing
a significant amount of transmission
occurring
and when you have a holiday like
christmas many more people from
different parts of the country where
there's different prevalences and
different
transmission dynamics are all going to
be mixing together and this is going to
happen at a time when hospitals already
have a record number
of people in them so this is kind of as
dr fauci has said a surge upon a surge
upon a surge now basically because of
thanksgiving and christmas
so we have we don't really see you know
any kind of respite for us in the
hospitals and i think that's the biggest
concern is that hospital capacity gets
compromised
the takeaway here clearly do not let
your guard down dr amish dolga
thank you so much